Today we are learning English with Toy Story!
We’re going to look at a couple
iconic scenes from the second movie.
And if you want to keep learning with the
best movies and TV series so you can finally
understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles, then just click on
the subscribe button and bell down below.
Like community member Nora who says
that she is amazed that thanks to our
channel now she can understand more
70% of movies when she watches them!
And do you get frustrated when natives speak fast
like this, and you can’t understand? Do you feel
lost and confused if you don’t have the subtitles?
Now it is not important that you speak this way.
But mastering connected speech like this
is absolutely crucial if you want to
confidently understand native speakers.
And this is exactly why in our Fluent
with Friends course we help you to
learn the principles of connected speech
so that you can understand natives at any speed!
The best part? You can try it absolutely free
with our 3-part masterclass. Just click here or
in the description down below to join that now!
I hope you enjoyed learning with Toy Story 2
today. If you can’t get enough of lessons with
your favorite TV series, movies, and songs, then
make sure you follow us on Instagram because we
make new lessons there every single day.
Next, I would recommend that you learn
English with this lesson from the first Toy
Story. Let’s check out a clip from that!